all right what's going on guys this is
rob and episode 5 of wanda vision was
absolutely insane but here's what i'm
going to do i want to talk about the
ending i want to talk about this ending
here and i want to focus almost
exclusively on the ending there's all
kinds of other stuff that happens over
the course of the episode to basically
show that juana's control is diminishing
over her little dimension or
that like mephisto or most likely
nightmare if you ever read captain
america volume 3
back in the 1990s when nightmare took
over captain america and then
wanted to conquer the world and all that
kind of stuff something you guys may not
know nightmare can possess people and
then use their powers when they're
possessed right so it may be something
like that but for right now i just want
to focus
on what's going on with the ending of
one division so as most everybody knows
by this point and if you haven't seen
this i don't know why you clicked on a
video called one division episode five
ending explained and then got
mad because there was not a spoiler
alert but for most everybody who has
seen this
we have evan peters quicksilver who's in
one division now now here's the thing it
could just be a random thing
but it could just be like you know what
is doing it for the giggles and that's
basically it but we're going to assume
that this
really is evan peters quicksilver from
fox
and so at the end of juan division
assuming that he survives to the very
end and that he makes it outside of
wanda's bubble that he's kind of like
where what is this place
right like and he goes running to
westchester and there's no xavier
institute and he was like where
am i what's going on here right he
doesn't understand how he ended up in
this place and then he's just here now
and the question becomes how do we get
to that point you know how do we get to
a point where if it really is evan
peters
quicksilver and nothing's happened up to
this point to indicate that the x-men
from fox
are now officially rolled over into the
marvel cinematic universe then how do we
get from a to b
in marvel comics there was a story that
came out in the aftermath of age of
ultron called
cataclysm and this was a story that
basically dealt with the idea
that in the age of ultron story because
ultron had conquered the past
while operating in the future that
wolverine kept going back in time
using doctor doom's time platform and
marvel basically established that time
was not just a thing that existed that
is kind of like a living entity it's
like a rubber band and if you travel
back in time too much
you'll basically break time and the
result of this is that it led to the
space-time continuum just going
haywire like it basically just went nuts
it was like it was it was like
it's like it exploded not literally but
something akin to that and it led to all
these crazy instances where characters
from other universes
were traveling to other universes they
weren't really choosing to they were
just whisked away and the main marvel
universe galactus was actually sent over
to the ultimate universe which is where
the marvel cinematic universe is largely
based on
but that's my thought here we know that
like the time variance authority is
going to be important in
loki and the time variance authority
plays the role of making sure that the
space-time continuum is held intact now
i think it'd be kind of cool that if we
looked at the events of infinity war in
avengers in-game we look at the idea of
the avengers going back in time
different things like that
they did it the first time in order to
take the infinity stones then they did
it a second time in order to put the
stones back to where they were supposed
to be
basically meaning the infinity stones
are intact in the marvel cinematic
universe as it exists right now just
not in the same location they were
before probably just they've moved
around a little more since they were
originally put back because technically
thanos never actually gathered them
in order to assemble the infinity
gauntlet so if we take that concept and
we roll this over
then what it really looks like here is
that it's entirely possible that the
space-time continuum really is broken
it's one of the things they talked about
in doctor strange that manipulating time
isn't manipulating time that it's
violating and abusing the space-time
continuum if you do it enough times
you can break it and there's room for
marvel to introduce the idea that this
has actually happened right i mean i
wouldn't go as far as to say that the
avengers traveling back in time in
avengers in game to take the infinity
stones bring them to the present day use
them and then travel back in time again
to put them back where they were
supposed to be i wouldn't say
that's enough action to destroy the
space-time continuum but i will say that
doctor strange
looking through every single scenario
during the events of infinity war and
then ultimately giving up the time stone
to
thanos might be enough to impact it
thanos rewinding time in order to uh to
basically reconstitute vision so we can
get the mind stone that could impact it
as well at this point i'm just kind of
spitballing and ball parking but if we
say
that that's the case that's actually
what happened and the space-time
continuum is in effect broken it
wouldn't really be that hard for scholar
rich to reminisce on the idea of her
brother and if she cannot truly bring
him back from the dead
then just subconsciously wish him to
come back and then he basically just
gets snatched out of the fox universe
and then brought over to the marvel
cinematic universe now i know that's
super thin that's a suit that's like a
paper thin
theory on this but at this point we
don't really have much else to go on
we don't really have much else to go on
but it does fit neatly
into everything else that's going to be
happening in the marvel cinematic
universe right if we take the multiverse
of madness and we we take the name
and we look at it literally then if the
space-time continuum is basically broken
and the multiverse is now what amounts
to a whole bunch of pool balls just
smacking against each other on a pool
table the universes are smashing
together they're crossing over
characters are bouncing in and out of
universes there's absolute chaos out
there we don't know it's chaos out there
because right now we're smoking we're
focusing on a small town in west view
but if you take a step back and you look
at everything that's going on like
presumably doctor strange might be doing
which is why he's currently not there
he's literally dealing with all this
insanity out there and then eventually
he traces it back to his origin point
which you know whatever that order point
happens to be it's not outside the realm
of possibility that with
weakening barriers between universes the
scarlet witch could just end up grabbing
evan peters now the question is
why him right why not just any other
alternate reality version of her brother
aaron taylor johnson right why not him
why not some alternate reality version
where he becomes the sorcerer supreme
instead of steven strange or
he becomes iron man instead of tony
stark well because we know that marvel
wants to roll the x-men over into the
mcu the x-men
are coming to the marvel cinematic
universe so what better way to kind of
begin this
crossing over process than to start with
evan peters who was just randomly
snatched out of his universe
because he's quicksilver and scarlet
witch wanted her brother back but when
you take this concept and you would
apply it to things like spider-man 3
where we're gonna end up seeing
the different versions of spider-man
that we've seen from different movie
properties over the years you look at
the events of doctor strange 2 where
you're going to have the entire
multiverse being brought into the
and brought into focus in the mcu then
it becomes a lot more clear and it
really
really seems possible as far-fetched as
it may appear to be
it really seems possible but again at
this point we just don't have enough
of evan peters it could very well be
that like he'll be in this episode
and that like at the end of the episode
he appears and then in episode six
wanda's like you're not my brother you
know and then just sends them away or
something along those lines that's
entirely possible for all we know
at the end of one division deadpool
could just happen to stroll through west
view and be like this is weird and he's
like the only person that affected any
leaves right that's entirely possible
you know it's really just a guessing
game i mean at this point i thought i
kind of had it figured out
i thought i had a good idea of what was
going on this threw me for a loop i am
legitimately
and truly stumped about what's going on
in wanda vision at the moment so i am
looking to you guys
i want to know your theories your ideas
do you think that evan peters is
mephisto who's masquerading as some guy
some version of quicksilver in order to
give wanda a hard time if he is
why isn't he looking directly like her
brother because that would mess with her
head even more if that were actually the
case
is it really just the beginnings of how
they're going to roll the the x-men
over into the marvel cinematic universe
do you think it's just random you're
just kind of like
just it's just a nice little tip of the
hat you know just kind of a nod to the
quicksilver in the fox universe and then
that's it that's all it's ever going to
be
right just a small little thing and
we're never gonna see evan peters in the
marvel cinematic universe again
when the x-men are officially rolled
over everybody will be recast right
professor xavier magneto quicksilver the
whole nine yards they'll all be recast
as holy new characters they'll get their
own origin
and it won't have anything to do with
with the character of evan peters i mean
let me know
what you guys think down in the comments
section because i'm really curious to
see
what your ideas are i do love reading
your comments i do love seeing what it
is you guys have to say because you guys
have some amazing ideas
in terms of how you guys think things
are unfolding but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this to an end
thanks for watching the video make sure
you guys check the end screen here for
our videos relating to one division and
our videos relating to
our celebrity explanations if you're
interested in that we just explained
black panther recently we're gonna be
explaining beyonce here in the next
couple days so on monday at the time
that i'm recording this video and
yeah i will catch you all later
peace